it's time to make some wrong things
right I max just has really large
screens that are fantastic and they have
this new thing
IMAX laser which is a really bright
sharp image it looks amazing I think
that emotionally people don't realize
how much differently movies affect you
when they're big
my name is Brynn and McGary shading art
director I'm so excited to see what it
looks like cuz I love to go to IMAX and
see everything on such a huge screen so
I can't wait
my name is Maya abou Sadie and I am the
director of photography for the camera
and staging department yeah it'll be
exciting to see the the scope of how
this feels when it's just so
encompassing the whole screen our goal
is to cinematically translate the boards
into the 3d space for software IMAX is
not just the visuals that's a great
that's a great auditory experience
my name is Nathan Farris I am the set
supervisor we make the props we make the
architecture both inside and out we do
all the vehicles we do all the
vegetation we don't make it move that's
a simulation department but we do make
the make the stuff and we do skies and
we do what we call set extensions I mean
the bigger the better like if you can
see it on a gigantic screen you're gonna
be able to see all those little things
and really can't soak it all in
so I'm feel watchful eye was the effect
supervisor on I - it's gonna be big
one of the cool things about animated
films is we do meticulously kind of
craft every pixel I think for us as
filmmakers seeing it at that scale is
gonna be super cool I think for the
audience as well there's so much visual
richness being incredible - I can only
imagine that on the IMAX screen that's
gonna give you the best opportunity to
really enjoy all the detail we put into
it if there's an IMAX theater somewhere
near you you should go to it
[Music]
[Music]